[Music]
we roll the roller rolling starting the
show yeah yeah yeah another episode of
the show your host Hannibal Burres your
co-host Tony [ __ ] special guest first
time on the show from when co-stars in
the new inside the comedy in theaters
June 15 shake Josie
[Music]
all right Johnson what's up man what's
up man thanks for coming on the show
yeah let's talk about how much fun we
hit over at Six Flags before we get to
that how to say that of all our guests
you've taken to the theremin with the
most comfort it needs right into yeah
sometimes people like what you are
little before I was before yeah but then
once you realize what's going on yeah
damn right here I think that's a good
description of how I do think I'm not in
I'm not even give you all the rules
[ __ ] I'm gonna go walk around get my
comfort zone check out the house yes and
then once I was like oh you guys are
doing music to start this yeah fun fact
Tony we both are good friends with
Serengeti Tony's DJ so yeah I saw the
interview those funny talking about
Dennehy yeah yeah yeah met Brian Dennehy
who sang again he has a song dinna give
my best I love it he's like we're
excited to talk to him he's like iconic
Chicago figure yeah yeah honestly Brian
Dennehy before that song was like I
thought he was cool yeah I would never
say my favorite actors that my favorite
actors denny know that song is just so
funny that I really started to love
Denny it's obscure cuz he talks about
Tom Berenger a lot yeah he's like
behringer sniper 1 2 & 3 it is such a
funny song yeah it's amazing that was
like his hit yeah and Danna he was so
not game with that it was like such an
easy bit to like get the whole crew in
the song is not teasing him it's
celebrating them but he was he you said
he refused even give me a chance I'll
tell mine you tell yours so mine was you
know he shows up to work we're shooting
this weird scene he plays my dad in it
you know I've heard that song probably
five thousand times
every time I see Danny he I think yeah
well you relate because you're from
Evanston right okay yeah yeah and so I
was excited mmm and so I'm trying to
find my way in to start doing bits with
them because we're about to act together
we're not small talk and he has no idea
who I am when they introduce he just
does like a hey how are you with you I'm
like I don't care about but in about
eight minutes they're gonna turn the
cameras on and we need to form something
yeah it's as bad and slow and awkward as
this yeah we're supposed to be your
mother and son yeah but we gotta find
something yeah when they call action
that this is gonna have to work room and
I thought this is a great way to do it
because also the song is a celebration
and if he has fun with it we could play
it the whole crew could chat favorite
actor Dennis so I was like man this song
poet he gives me a look I'm like yeah
it's great I've heard some about that
I'm like yeah I know and it's all a
celebrant can i play and he goes I don't
want to hear the song so I'm sitting
there with my dick in my hand where I'm
like watch me do this like over show to
like show respect and I just act my
phone was out whose download and I was
like I'll just let me play for the sound
guy in a corner so it all so you had
this like fantasy or you it all played
out of your head where I let you guys
bound oh yes everything's gonna be great
the sound guy hug hooks it up to a
speaker and all of a sudden we get to do
it in between takes is it was it was he
a grump about it it's just grumpy
he just wasn't he wasn't there to play
yeah just there to work and get out
kinda yeah cuz I think I met him maybe
the day before when he was coming in to
do his his fitting and I would not even
I don't have any scenes with him I just
man I was like Brian Dennehy here okay
he wants to hear also side know I
couldn't tell you what he acted in I
just know that yeah that same daddy made
that song you to do from the song and
this by the way same yeah I don't know
what he's been and so I think the day
before they you cuz you did it during
shooting yeah I didn't day before it now
they ate is this song about you and I
started playing it and then he was like
I get it before the hook even came up it
was just a build-up and the hook I think
comes in it wave say yeah I'd be 40
seconds or so in yeah not I get it maybe
it's just cuz he's me anti rap maybe he
just just doesn't [ __ ] a rap like that
sorry or he's got bad hearing because I
just thought there could be a thing that
when he was talking to you about it you
said I planted he couldn't hear she
liked it do you know he's not a younger
guy hmm so there could be that moment of
rather than say you know I'm having a
hard time here and this and I'm not
gonna pull it off yeah he tried to
squash with you and then when I came up
with it again he was like not this
[ __ ] my nightmare is trying to hear
things on people's phones that's I don't
I don't understand how anyone could
dislike that's like that song is so good
even Tom York tweeted about it oh he did
and was just like I can't remember what
he said but he was just like yeah
Serengeti kenny dennis is the name of
the character so he so serengeti is his
real rap name and then he goes by this
alias kenny Dennis that's a big
backstory you wrote about being like
this Chicago superfan who's a recovered
alcoholic only drinks all dole dole
spares that makes a little bit more
sense there because I'm like yeah you're
close with the orange pop and the
Oldsmobile a favorite beer old-style not
like you're not drinking o'doole no
there's a whole story
yeah and like yeah he's a big my OneNote
he's in the video hmm they should have
grown those real mustaches out yeah well
they did that like ended they did that
like they I don't even think they were
gonna release it I think they just does
it by the way like the softball they're
all goofing around I mean the look of
that video everything about it I love
yeah I'm like guys take the two months
way to get some real now we got such a
goldmine I was working with them back
then we were on just some like
independent label and it was just like
it was just steai it was stupid just
having fun type [ __ ] it's like Sergei
he's a big softball fan like for his new
record releases that he had oh yeah for
his record release it was like we're
gonna have a softball party so like you
just invite people to the park and
everyone's playing softball no music
playing nothing is just everybody plays
softball that my records come out that's
one part of Chicago I've never connected
to my buddy Nick excitement that guy I
was telling you about in Chicago you
know his big thing is he's in like he
got recruited in like a co-ed softball
league rooted yeah he's not there it's a
swingers club that brought him in to
play and I was like oh so you're
involved in a weird sex thing and he's
like no I'm just really good it's awful
but it involved for real no he's not
part of the I mean he maybe he's part of
all that I don't know but when I've
asked about that I'm like so you're in a
swingers thing there's no like it gets
so crazy it you know it's all we've won
seven in a row
really everyone's into softball
Chicagoans take their softball serious
yeah softball and barbecuing and
grilling I get the barbecue and grilling
but I'm like no want some insight on
this recruiting process like blue chips
that's I'm not sure him hey what did
they get him Wiener circle gift cards I
know he's a dude he's an athletic guy
he's good at softball his name is Nick
excitement
the swingers clubs the perfect place for
so uh so you're born in Evanston yeah
and I saw that you went to New Trier
yeah I have a lot of homies that uh went
enough I'm from dis Plains original okay
yeah so I went to Maine West okay and uh
so you're like Northwest Suburbs kind of
a guy huh so did you make the transition
into Chicago or did you go straight to
well my path la we at 15 I was in New
Trier and I dropped out of high school
for a year
whoa yeah I didn't tell you that no that
didn't come up so I knew chairs very
great yeah yeah if you are a individual
who fits the system mm-hmm if you can
work really hard and your heads out
straight your you can go from there to
Harvard wherever know if you're not they
have like a new chair West which is
where the kids go when you're starting
to get in trouble so that your test
scores don't go against their test go oh
wow yeah it's like it's like one of
those yeah filter hey we gotta keep this
goal but it's also numbers they have it
here with private schools in LA you'll
start seeing like you know I got young
kids now so as I'm asking around you'll
find out like certain schools you'll be
like Oh after fifth grade kids can be
asked to leave this school Wow and I'm
like how could you ask a kid to leave
and then when I get in the back story
it's because they're not testing high
and they want those tests at a certain
level so anyway long story short I
dropped out for a year and then we had
some financial stuff as a family and we
moved to Evanston right near Howard and
I was coming back and I was gonna go to
Evanston Township but I was starting
over a year younger and I didn't have a
huge desire to go back to school so we
said that I still lived where we lived I
said I moved in with a neighbor and I
was gonna go back to New Trier and so I
finished new treer 'even though I was in
Evanston with my family and I bounced
around Chicago a tiny bit but I was out
at 19 well yeah a year like out of
school 15 and out of school yeah it was
really a mistake
it was I was so my uncle Edie was living
with us he was having legal troubles and
he was there and I just thought of
daytime television would it make you
like all day a lot of love a lot of
victory auto record commercials what oh
right what it really was with it was he
made neon signs so he was a small town
business a small time the business guy
always trying to like figure out work so
it was a year of now that I'm not going
to school I have to do something
so it was entering the workforce and
seeing what that would feel like to own
your own little business go to shops on
Clark Street and you know for $400 say
we can put a sign up and then trying to
figure out how much you can make the
sign for and it just sucked did you ever
did you ever consider going to DeVry or
the Peter Francis geraci yeah Peter for
sure no that was the year and then that
was the year I decided when I go back to
school I'm gonna have a clear vision of
what I want to do because I wanted to
make money and I wanted to enjoy and
that was it's going to be writing and
writing could lead to acting but it's
going to be this one specific thing
right until going to school made sense
I'm never gonna be good at math I'm
never going to understand biology I'm
never gonna understand you know I'll
remember all the historical dates yeah
but if I can I can excel at theatre and
in English then that's all you need
yeah dojo so then right so how long did
it take for you to get your first role
or first money job yeah I was 28 28 yeah
27 28 took you but I went to college
after college was working day jobs I did
you see B I had a two-man show for a
while so call the Midwesterners yeah we
were doing sketch comedy in the lower
Eastside of the back in the day when it
was like Pink Pony were you when did you
do your New York time 2000
six for a few months in in 2008 so you
were a little bit after yeah but there
wasn't like the pink pony then or a surf
reality a collective uh surf reality own
of it I when I visited okay it's so
crazy over my yeah so that's where we
used to do our comedy show cuz we could
rent that place out for $300 yeah but
like those were there places and then
UCB people came and saw us there and
that's how we got to use TV um with surf
reality did you ever do the open mic -
no face boy's open mic no what was that
like it was just super experimental
we're especially coming from Chicago and
only you know it was a lotta is a
vibrant open mic scene in Chicago but it
was mostly you know straightforward I am
a poet or I am a comedian oh I'm a
musician right this is what I do and
maybe some you know venture out with the
comedy and then you get a surf reality
and then somebody dessert yes up on
stage naked people just that's how
you're gonna go and do a naked poem okay
I didn't know that was that's was that's
been going on I didn't know that's what
you could do reality was just like a
weirdo open mic you know I went back to
visit if not it was like a I went back
to visit cuz it closed it down and a
friend of mine when I was back in New
York to impress we walked by and all the
places we performed I think it was just
somebody who rented out the space and
got a really good deal on it back when
the Lower East Side was still cheap and
wanted to have a place to perform with
their friends and then open it up to
others but it was like a weird clubhouse
thing right yeah and it was a it was a
just a group of performance that were
regulars at that open mic and then it
was one at Bowery Poetry Club it had
some of the people and Reverend Jin and
it was oh yeah I never of that yeah and
it was a certain group that performed
and they would allow you know
traditional stand-up so other musicians
will perform there too but there were
definitely you know maybe 10 to 15 the
celebrities of it that only perform at
the angel and mics but they would have
like because we could do I could do a
sketch there or I would
like a character I created and I could
do a character and one of their things
within that world there was a hierarchy
and like there were people who you never
hear of outside no but they were kings
and queens these like weird little rooms
New York which is such a funny thing to
think about like where are those people
what happens when the night gets roast
no no it was really weird
yeah I don't know how you could break it
wasn't like a lot of people weren't even
performing anything they were just
experimenting with space didn't have
those ambitions just be just that outlet
that's right I need I need I need to get
naked and say stuff and I'm doing it for
eight minutes in front of you yeah and
I'd be like sitting there wait I'm going
next we're doing a straight-up sketchy
as a launching pad for my career and it
was so naked guy goes up this I'm crazy
what will your follow-up being so in a
sketch show it was done with two of my
good really good friends and then people
would you know leave and come back but
we were trying to copy mr. show okay so
Bob and Dave do mr. show what I loved
about it was how they would do
transitions amazing all right I thought
it was Jay and I also loved how those
guys were playing three-dimensional
characters I've never liked sketch where
it's throw a goofy wig on and you're
goofy wig guy that's not the [ __ ] that
makes me laugh what makes me laugh is
when I see somebody and I'm like oh like
David Cross is playing this guy and it's
real acting but what he's doing is
ridiculous so we tried to copy that so
we would do if we were doing to do a two
person thing we'd do it there or we
would have solo characters so I would
create a character and I'd be
workshopping it for our sketch show so I
could sometimes take that to those
places but they never played because
I've never been like a joke writer so I
didn't have like a great bit right all
right now we're gonna improvise is this
guy and I wasn't ever in the hierarchy
of the theaters yeah so I'd be like
they'd be like next up Reverend whoever
now like blah blah blah big cheers now
Jake do you have old footage of any of
this stuff yeah I did I had a weird
thing where and my buddy and I had a bit
about Jerry Seinfeld's comedian how he
was saying he just goes on the road and
this is what it must this is what it's
like for comedians who are workshop and
stuff and at the time I was living in
Brooklyn I was really broke and I was on
these stages all the time and I really
disagreed with that movie because I
thought that's not what it's like for me
at all when I go on stage people hate me
with your sudden felt goes on stage
people love him
so his workshop is a durable and you are
dying to see the brain of Jerry Seinfeld
my workshop is [ __ ] this guy I hate who
is this he has to kill it so we had a
joke idea and that was let's create a
thing called Project joke where we go on
the road and create a show in a week and
you know had people watch us and blah
blah blah
long story short we talked about on the
phone we had a bunch of bits I was with
my buddy Simon in Oklahoma writing a
script and his uncle we had a drunken
night with his uncle a self-made guy and
the uncle was doing that drunken kind of
coqui alcohol night where he was piling
his fists I made my money this is what
you got to do follow your dream
[Music]
mid-twenties here a lot of for people
closer to 40 and so sitting there
getting my free drinks being like Yemen
you've done great beautiful house man
while the wall caught you've done it man
congratulations
wait did speaking of the drunken stuff
was it I think I've read something's
like didn't you inspire the drunken
history stuff yeah I was part of it what
was the yeah what was it what was the
story I always thought that that show
was fascinating because it just it's
it's it's it's it's own thing there's
nothing like like it and I read some
article where it said like you and their
waters yeah yeah what's the what was
that Derek and I Derek was one of the
first guys I met out here he helped kind
of get me started and one night we went
to my place on Rowena which is literally
three blocks from this place and got
cow trunk when we just said let's have a
night where we just hang out at the
place and get drunk and this was
pre-internet year where you could
double-check everything we were just
bullshitting and telling stories and I
have a story about Otis Redding and then
that he died that my buddy bill Bunga
Roth one of my Chicago guys who I
performed this would always tell
so I told Derek the story it's probably
a three minute story tops it took about
45 minutes to tell and that was the next
day he calls me up and he said can I
come back tonight I'll get you a bunch
of booze and we'll get our buddy Jeremy
Konner who's the director of the whole
show to film you telling that story and
I said why and he goes cuz I want to
film it then I want to get a bunch of
actors to reenact then I want to get
someone to play Otis Redding to be
sitting next to you and just being like
like it felt like Derek waters came out
of nowhere is it was he already let me
go he was a series regular on the show
before that oh he was quietly deep in
the game he had done a show with Simon
Helberg from the Big Bang Theory okay
that Bob Odenkirk had directed so within
the Insider of it Derek was pretty deep
in okay he just hadn't popped yet I like
that you know that's the he's you
telling this drunk story and he's just
thinking the high concept that's just
kind of not in Derek's the best man he
made it work and then you were on you
you did a couple episodes right yeah I
did the so then I wouldn't be the first
drunk so I said no no I was like man I'm
trying to get work here I can't get
wasted on camera so he got our other
friend Mark to do it and then me and
Mike Sarah did the first one for YouTube
that kind of blew up and then I've done
a few of them since they've been on
Comedy Central
yeah I remember when they first came out
on YouTube that [ __ ] was so funny so
funny I used to just watch those like
I'll repeat the fun and I would like did
be one of those videos where he put your
friends on to you be like yeah for sure
he's gonna watch dude it was one of
those first ones yeah yeah but he was
doing that
youssef a show at UCB and it reminded me
of the surf reality days because it was
called lol and he would just do a show
where you could make any video and he
would you know select 15 of them and
play them but those were like packed
houses yeah
and it's when I first moved to LA don't
be like the [ __ ] is Seth Rogen doing
here how Martin start hanging out
backstage and I was like cuz I'd come
from the surf reality world right and so
I'm like man LA is different yeah Bob
Odenkirk is hanging out directing the
show I do a little bit with Derrick and
then all of a sudden I'm like oh okay
how did you get into that so how'd you
wedge yourself into that circle look I
moved into a building on Las Palmas
sunset in Las Palmas yeah and my
roommate the guy who lived in my
building actually is a guy named Eric
Edelstein who's a great actor he was in
the green room in Jurassic world 2
he knew Derek and Simon and all these
guys in Jason Ritter we all just we did
a sketch show Eric and I all those guys
came Jeremy Konner who directed drunk
history wanted to shoot one of our
sketches that sketch ended up selling to
NBC and so I kind of lucked into that
whole group wow that's a great story
lucky and then that that ultimately led
to new girl I was doing that for a
little bit and then I met max Winkler
through that world he had did some
shorts video that I did a little short
with my and Mike Cera was in that we
improvised a lot and Max did an indie
movie and while he was editing that
movie at his dad's house
aka Henry Winkler mm-hmm Liz
Merriweather who created new girl was
there with max writing a movie and he
showed her a cut of it and she contacted
me and said let's find something to work
on and then you know a year later that
was new girl Wow and look at you now
wearing shorts and an Airbnb
[Laughter]
talk about hey at Six Flags doing a
stunt for yeah it was okay what was that
I saw I saw something about that six
flex their take first uh they they've
been the Warner Brothers machine is
fully activated I'm happy to keep my
hamster wheel going off for the press
everything I mean do it we're all
pushing everyone hard we all love the
move and we're pushing it what did you
make of that Guinness guy cuz that guy
from Guinness with the sports jacket
he's not part of Warner Brothers right
so I think it's safe to be able to talk
openly about him take on him and the
Guinness Book of World Records that was
I mean I guess it really had to be
official yeah so he was there to make
sure everything was on the up and up to
set the world record for free standing
now I'm gonna interview you over here if
you're okay with that
alright Guinness Book of World Records
when I was young felt like a very big
thing it felt like a bit like if you got
a Guinness absolutely it was like you
must have some really special skill was
that the way for you yeah absolutely you
just meant something huge thing did you
take him as a real judge of these
extraordinary events or did you take him
as a weird guy in a blazer make it a
little bit aside he seemed I mean I
don't know he the British accent I
wasn't around him enough to see if it
was real if he was legitimate that route
like yeah don't they have to wear a
certain type of jacket brown widow just
like it was a generic not expensive
sports coat with a Guinness
he was like an officer well he was in a
rental car so you know he wasn't from
there he like grabbed the airport got it
well rented dodge dodge what one of
those like little white dodges that
you're so he's not rich see so is I mean
like so he thought Dart
a Dodge Charger
you know ourselves watch you by the end
of that I was pretty hot in a bad
everything we've learned together yeah
you if I pulled it together yeah yeah
whether to go we took the picture that
was my worst moment let's just take the
picture though
don't assume Jake does not operate well
under heat well here's what it was for
me because I had to do when you guys
were on the ride I did a little self
talking you know I was like I slowed
down yeah here's what I didn't like
about that event it felt like it was a
great idea first a thing mm-hmm and then
nobody then nobody in a human level was
being fully taken care of
you had seven hundred people who signed
on who paid to get in the park to play
tag with us right nobody got paid the
whole idea was there trying to get 800
people to play a game of freeze tag and
if you do that for whatever 15 minutes
you're in the Guinness Book of World
Records but there was a record before
this yes and what was that number 509 I
don't know something like but they held
I kept saying it all right so I thought
we're gonna come out there they're going
to Warner Brothers are spending some
money to do this there's probably gonna
be something like big weird tent with
a/c pumping in for everybody so that
like these people don't faint yeah yeah
we're probably gonna be pretty lacs with
the game it's gonna be fun for everybody
we get there it is so hot mmm we get on
the screen you look at the people they
looked like zombies
yeah then when it starts the official in
the jacket keeps yelling like no phones
yet you can't put freeze tag with a
phone it's not official sure the [ __ ]
you can you play free second a phone in
your hand then once you got tagged
anybody can untag you so there was no
like hard rural game it was just 15
minutes of chaos yeah just 15 minutes of
people walking around keep moving but
you couldn't run and you couldn't go on
your phone and you couldn't ask us for a
photo and you couldn't stop for water
and we have microphones we're supposed
to encourage people to keep going yeah
there was at about minutes
I was like this feels like it could have
been planned a little bit you can still
play freeze tag indoors that's sounds
like a lawsuit waiting to happen
I was like one bad faint but they have
you know everybody and then for me and
the judge guy Mike Mellon could be a
question him was so what's gonna really
happen you're gonna go in the back and
say we didn't get it what is what did
you say too many people were on the
phones
there would have been a riot after all
that from those people if they said
unfortunately some of you five-year-old
kids who were with and you're like
parens arms we cannot count you know
record like you're just all run I mean
people aren't rides and stuff towards
he's just running around the park area
to park but a Batman right but then they
did the when they presented it with the
ward and got and get it was like alright
this is a fun thing people are happy
yeah yeah do you guys you guys enjoyed
yourselves it was hot it was hot I was
so excited when we landed in there and
stepped off the plane and it was
whatever 68°
probably the happiest so I you know
honestly the what I personally like
about the movie is I like the cast a lot
so Hannibal and I had a ton of fun to
impress you know it's been a blast I
like to talk getting to know John better
yeah jon Hamm's a man yeah yeah metaphor
- okay awesome it's a really sweet guy
Renner's cool he's worn his own world
but he's never anything but nice now
yeah then they say yeah they're like CGI
his [ __ ] arms and [ __ ] and did a
movie yeah he really did break both his
arms yeah and then so but I don't
remember like sleeves or anything do you
yeah I don't remember the CGI stuff or
any green I heard they might have to but
in his benefit he did all the scenes you
know so while we were there like he had
cast and not only had braces on but
sometimes he took him off so the movie I
think could have worked but I think in
order to be extra
safe they think CJ deserves but there's
nothing about his arms that are how did
he break his arms again fell off a
ladder and then just he does his own
stunts
I mean we all do some of them you know
for in terms of the stunts if you're
like jumping off something they do need
you to jump because they don't get the
beginning and they don't get you landed
what the stunt guys do that we don't do
is they don't have wires so if we're
gonna do a jump we still have to jump
off something but ideally those wires
are to protect you in the stunt guys
what makes them way tougher than us is
they will jump up my character falls
three stories off a building and lands
on his back Jesus Christ so I did the
jump over the thing and then I'm hanging
in the air and I did the things where I
fall down well he just jumped off a
building at a certain point banged into
a car and he's gonna cut up and you know
they act really like tough guys but I'm
like how bad did that one hurt he's like
as bad as you would think you know I'm
not Rock I fell off a building and
attack what was the craziest [ __ ] that
made you guys do in the movie where you
had the question anyway you to be like
oh if I should do this one was the crazy
I mean what was the craziest one I mean
it was it was fun even acting like we
were about the water war Thomas
Middleditch no it was something about
that even though it was fake like yeah
we're waterboarded something about me
where I connected today oh this is what
his like cuz we set him up we had the
water ready
we covered his face we didn't do it well
okay and we yeah we did that a few times
yeah
felt it felt good yeah what uh so new
girl was how many seasons we did seven
years of seven years would you would you
do seven years of another series
yeah I guess that's uh yeah that's not a
trick question but it depends is
situationally specific I was I was in a
different age when I got that I was 33
oh yeah so I'm four I just turned 40 so
going from 40 to 47 yeah you know and my
kids ages right now I'm like you know
pilot season came and I was looking at
stuff and it gets tempting right I mean
seven years is for real yeah but it's
wrapped up now though right I was over
yeah okay how much have broad city have
you done we've done we're going into the
fifth season and that's still going
strong that's fifth seasons gonna be the
last season yeah I think I don't know
Comedy Central said we're not gonna pay
you well you guys deserve and they said
I think five is a good number and it's
five at ten episodes a season time
they've done 50 so it'll be 50 and I did
about four to five per season okay yeah
that's just getting like same way yeah
like they haven't even peaked yet unless
they've got those two girls have like a
secret thing they're working on which
I'm sure they're yeah that is still
developing stuff but a really nice thing
it's been crazy man it's uh it was
interesting seeing you know cuz I had
before I did Eric Andre show and stand
up and you know popped up in some stuff
but with broad city that's when I had
got to really feel how the general
public connects with story yes you are
the character and they like you for it
or they don't like you for you and it's
just a different feel it's try out and
about where you know people just like
your as you Wow
why'd you break up with her see she
wrote it like that
everybody thinks he's like you know like
a dentist fun-loving guy that's in the
puppies and [ __ ] what if somebody would
actually let me do dental work like pull
a tooth yes super fan they allow you to
do something for the fun of a supervised
tooth removal so how they for how they
find you for broad cities so you were
performing oh I know you were a writer
for a while I was performing in New York
I just met them if one I got a little
show it uh Parkside lounge I think I met
them initially and just would see them
around and then they did it was a web
series first oh yeah that's right as
well webisodes
yeah and they asked me to do a webisode
and now it was fun and then they got
they got Amy Poehler to be in the finale
of that that the web series and then she
told them to develop a full-length
script a half-hour script and didn't
when it was an FX initially accident oh
I didn't know that yeah didn't get
picked up at FX and Comedy Central
Comedy Central swooped in
Wow I mean it's uh it's funny because
your your character I mean it's still
you but it's not you know obviously
you're not a dentist and you're not
really in the puppies like that right
but you seem like from what our
conversation so far I feel like you were
playing yourself a guy from Chicago kind
of blue-collar doing how much different
are you you think from the character
that you play well I mean I get that
like it's a tricky question because you
know he looks like me yeah if I did it
for 150 episodes so he dresses like me
yeah when somebody tries to put me in
like a really tight fitting suit and I
got to work a 12-hour day in it I think
we're gonna ask wardrobe to loosen up
the suit a little bit so he all of a
sudden the Styles more like me when we
improvise and you're doing bits with
people there's a rhythm of what you
improvise that is my rhythm mm-hmm I
just got a thing on social media where
that the clip from el gordo y la flaca
this year we did we're at the end we're
dancing and then a little person runs
out
all right nak said in the in the nuts
and jumps over couch a joke more though
I really liked it and I posted it and I
was getting a bunch of responses on it
saying like well he even dances like
Nick Miller
[Laughter]
if I'm in a scene and they say stand up
and dance yeah well I'm not gonna go
like salsa lessons to learn how to
dancing this character but what am I
actually like him in real life mm-hmm no
I mean he is a fictional character who
belongs in that world yeah there's
really no links like you know his whole
bid is he's this slacker who can't
figure anything out and he doesn't have
any Drive but he's a sweet guy mm-hmm
well I agree what there's like a
sweetness I really like about him but I
didn't move it I'm good I'm not like
still living in Chicago mmm I came up
here with really heavy Drive
I didn't party for years if I was doing
something and it wasn't leading to work
I cut it off mmm there wasn't a time I
would leave LA my wife says now there's
like a four year period where I wouldn't
leave in case somebody called with an
opportunity I would go to Chicago for
Christmas but it'd be three days we're
not know for sure there's not a
commercial audition Wow I had one pet
because I also don't have the stand-up
I'm always jealous of you know people
who have other ways to make money when I
was first started it was there's one way
I make money and that somebody calls and
gives me an opportunity right so why did
you never mind why don't you try to
dabble in standup I'm not a wildly
social guy mm-hmm I like a small group I
don't like being out and about with too
many people for too much I don't like
big crowds and I don't like the bar
scene so the idea of having to do that
bar scene and dealin with it just never
sound fun actually doing the work would
scene it fun but like you know the way I
have a lot of respect for comedians when
they like deal with a drunken table it
mine would be like [ __ ] [ __ ] off
forget the mic I don't want to do bits
with you I hate you you guys got three
I'm gonna get two others let's just
handle this you guys
you're not a drinker I mean I do I do
drink but I'm not like a on a Friday
night let's all go to a bar drink
oh okay cuz that's a different story
because if you don't drink and you just
don't want to be around drunks but I
also like yeah I do drink I like to
drink but on a Friday night I've never
been a guy saying let's all go to a club
yeah I would rather if we were all in
town yeah and we want to I'm not against
getting a bottle of booze but it would
feel something like this
yeah with a couple other friends here
which is better yeah the bar I mean
unless the bar is you know yes I'm going
on an arcade bar arcade food or
something maybe watching like a big
sports game but for the most part
chilling at home with drinks in a
controls better environment where nobody
can get any stranger yes that's a I've
been this way since I was 21 years old
okay so this didn't it wasn't a result
of like you know I got on TV and people
bothered me at 24 if I'm with my friends
and someone's like hey can I get the
ketchup I'm like stop bothering you know
yeah your table doesn't have ketchup I'm
so have you have you Jake so have you
embraced yourself for the forthcoming
people coming up to you and be doing
this I gotta say a lot of people have
warned me a lot about what it'll be when
you get recognized and all that and from
my personal experience I don't do a ton
of press I don't do a hard push I
haven't had a publicist in years so I'm
never looking to be front and center on
a project so my level of it is I'm not
expecting that what I get I mean just
for the tag no I get it yeah look I'm
not expecting in this day and age I'm
not expecting tag to be hangover you
have expected tag to ideally be
successful and make a lot it you know
make a lot of money but we're in a whole
new world of stuff yes I think more
it'll be what I've experiences
be everyone so while somebody will go
hey tag and you're like all right good
to see ya but if somebody runs up and
like hits me in an airport yeah I'm not
gonna like smile and take a selfie with
us there's a person you just ran up and
hit somebody you don't know yeah yeah
but in truth 99.9% of the world and
people that I've seen are so normal with
this stuff so I don't know worried about
it what you got planned for after after
the movie comes out vacation or gonna
work on something right yeah I'm right
I'm working on a idea right now with
some people I like Damon and I are
working on that script which we're just
finishing up a draft of and then just in
it you know I'm not a I got the kids in
school so when you talk about Hawaii it
sounds cool my tribe is different that's
I Drive up to big bears all right but no
just kind of stay in it how about you
what are you doing next I'm thinking
about doing
oh that Thailand thinking about going to
Thailand doing a kickboxing oh that's
right yes all about that two weeks two
or three what muay thai boot camp right
a Muay Thai camp it's a bunch of about
that yeah mark yeah Marcus did one of
those Marcus did a month out there
Marcus price if you do it bring this
thing and interview everybody there
that's all same like if you're gonna do
it when we were talking about that
restaurant of like make a competition of
it right that would be is just a random
person fun to watch Hannibal Buress goes
to Thailand to learn kick boxing for two
weeks and at the end you're gonna have
to do some sort of a class in front
where you're gonna have to like earn
your belt that you get yeah film that
[ __ ] I wonder if I'm gonna get get
caught up and you know what I'm that I'm
that tour yeah sorry we don't have to
cancer those September dates and San
Francisco Dallas Houston and Austin
document
some way yeah so you couldn't at least
have footage of you like the first day
yep not knowing how to [ __ ] elbow or
throw a knee and then three months later
you're a [ __ ] makasian killer yeah I
think so I mean I would like to kick a
deserving person in the face
mm-hmm no no strangers no random but if
somebody is like this person that's to
push me to it we tie a savage to like
you it's that one move where you locked
a few things behind them yeah and you
[ __ ] just take your knee right to
their goddamn jaw that's real
- yes
chickadee face
kick box kick - what box of bicycle kick
boxing
yeah what is this thing this is a
theremin is this do people use this
really when they're in the booth
recorded stuff is this like an
instrument that somebody's really good
at yeah it's uh I would say it's more of
supplement so you know like this is what
I do outside the thing no no no no there
yes some people play the theremin but
you know it could fit in on an on a song
and it got a bunch of other instruments
or sounds on there you can kind of get
in there but there definitely is uh you
know some people that are Pro theremin
players yeah how do you become a pro
theremin player that's the thing it's
not it's not like and in this it's not
like something that adheres to like
musical theory right so it's all like
just feeling it and just kind of going
with the it's just kind of going with
the vibe it's the original synthesizer I
don't know if you know this I don't know
that
so before so basically you know that
company mogh it's it looks like Moog and
yeah okay
so Bob Moog took this instrument and put
it in the keyboard for men that was the
first synthesizer but this was the
original synthesizer before it was in
keyboard format so events are in the 80s
or late 70s was yeah yes but this is
like the automated version this is like
the user-friendly sorry things like kind
of preset and everything but the real
ones every tiny little millimeter is a
huge change yeah like any movement of
your hand will so there's like if you go
on YouTube and you look up theremin
there's like people that could play like
the Zelda theme so that's okay so that's
a brocade that makes sense yeah you
somebody who's gets really good at it
you figure out how to move their hand
yes and all of a sudden you go you just
played that song yeah but it's not like
you can't read note plays it's in the
air yeah this is like a this is a this
is like muscle memory you have to teach
your your muscles how to use this it's
it's it's interesting it's an I would
like to see a Karate Kid version of that
with a teacher teaching somebody this
yeah because like a like a punky kid who
has no interest but yeah and like but
his hands are like or her hands are
really interesting huh and the teacher
goes like does he ever played one of
these make kids like that's nothing man
and then he goes like and it's really
good because what you're learning is
like you have to get in touch with the
spirit body the mind also with
technology it's not a C and a B it's
yeah you've got to feel it man you're
gonna lose it yes finally what makes the
instrument so amazing is the fact that
it's it's it's it's reading the energy
coming off of your hand it's so because
you're completing an electric circuit
right because I'll say the reason I ask
is when that first thing started I was
just goof around making sounds and then
there was a moment where I thought oh
I'm sounded all I'm doing is doing a
weird finger thing around it but I need
to keep going with those other music
because this is part of it yeah yeah
yeah all right this is all of us saying
like Oh interesting
and what's even cooler about is like
just like if you go
[Music]
that's nice you know what this is really
dangerous for cancer No oh is it a
problem no but what it's really
dangerous for is going through
depression find a bunch of grass and not
leave in your house yeah taking a lot of
hits we've already been through by
yourself you're like whatever man like
that what thing happened like I must
take a little bit and then one more big
hit and you just go like I don't want
waste my whole day a lot of time on that
you know that clip when we did that show
me down I got an idea for you
so we do a morning show in Dallas it's
me him John you know so they put the
mistake they made was they put John and
Ed in front and us behind them where
they couldn't see us yeah but we could
all see the monitor and then the shot
the head of and John is a pro when it
comes to press and he just I mean ever
he just answers it right is good so they
you know jump
tell us about tag it's based on a true
story is that wild and John goes into a
very good answer about how you know this
wouldn't have been a movie that wasn't
based on a true story and blah blah blah
behind him you see my face and then it's
John and then you see Hannibal's face so
we both checked they noticed the camera
or the camera on us look at each other
and the animal starts going he puts his
hands up I'm just doing this information
you want solid information
look at John Hamm if you want to go just
doing this on camera and I see the
director keeps all cutting away they had
so anytime they wanted a single of John
they getting to have a closer version
and John it was a 15 minute interview so
like and we talked they didn't have a
lot of questions for Hannibal and ice Oh
there's gonna be something but what you
should do is redo that clip and put this
over like your hands are making that
music whatever you have like you know
John talking and then when your
character sees this yeah or when you see
it just push in a little bit and then
you'd have like did you ever end up
getting your little Russian doll
theremin whatever happened to that I did
get it is that my parents crib oh you
gotta bust that out it was I think it
was Japanese I just I thought somebody
sent me a link to some random just weird
there man that's in the shape of and I
bought it at me I think it was like 400
bucks I was like so oh so this is your
thing you're deep into this as deep as I
was last year I kind of got into put a
focus but it still it all started with
this time the story of how we acquired
this so I got nieces and nephews and I I
was shopping on I was doing my online
shopping a few Christmases ago and I was
on Twitter people say hey what should I
get people for Christmas it'd be funny
if I got my dad a beat machine like I
think that'd be hilarious if I got my
dad like that and he started making
beats for trap rappers my nephew
somebody said get them up there man I
think I should get them a theremin so I
bought than that and then so I gave you
time at Christmas and then they play
with it a little bit and maybe a year or
so later Tony's like we should get it
there before the podcast now say wait a
second I got my niece and nephew a
theremin let me ask my sister how much
they're using it yeah
instead of just getting another a second
it's been played with four times
did I play that there was like nice and
sit it to Mom's house took that [ __ ]
back look back the name of America when
you gonna make a music album because if
you're sitting around doing this that
much there is a plan yeah well we got
some songs we make some we make some
jingles sometimes for our advertisers
and yeah we've been talking about
putting out I'll be putting the pressure
on busy go
sex focus we should have gotten a
goddamn tag soundtrack for sure let's do
let's see if we can make a lake
placement for the tag soundtrack
[Music]
commercials
[Music]
watch
[Music]
it's gonna set Academy Awards history I
like that I like it but I think it might
be too it needs a little tweaking it
might be too it might be too heavy for
you know when we did your daughter's do
they have awareness of what you do and
if so when did they gain that so when I
first when I first had kids I thought I
got to keep him listen for this this is
a weird way of life and then so for the
first two years it was nothing I didn't
want him to visit new girl I didn't want
him to see me it set and I thought that
was the way I was just gonna do it right
and then I did that Tom Cruise movie and
I would still keep it I was in London
for four months and this was the
beginning of like well this is weird
because this is gonna be in all their
baby photos now they're in London for
four months year like the River Thames
what are we doing here right and I
honestly thought I'd never worked with a
celebrity of that level that most people
most actors don't do anything for me
like if I you know when I see like a
fleet I'll trip out but if I see an
actor I don't care
Tom Cruise I cared I felt really weird
around him I couldn't believe it was Tom
Cruise and I thought I want a photo of
Tom Cruise of my babies that is funny
like that is different whatever happens
in 40 years there's I want a photo of
them with like you know my wife and Tom
Cruise we're all like doing a thumbs-up
so I brought him to set and it was just
really fun
yeah and they went to craft service and
got a bunch of candy and it also helped
my day because I'd be gone for 11 hours
and then all of a sudden we were all
hanging out of my trailer because you
know there's so much sitting around
right and I'm always a guy doing
something as you know where I might
build and [ __ ] in the trailer so I
thought rather than do that I can just
be with my family right and so I started
bringing him more and more and then they
would realize like like Annabelle Wallis
the day they came she was in a scene
where a wind machine we're doing stunts
was blowing her back so their first
memory of anything they call it
Annabelle in the wind
yeah so they'll just be like I'll be
like oh yeah when I did that movie the
middle Annabelle in the wind machine
takes her off they knew I hadn't learned
the name Tom Cruise when they said it
would be like really funny I go I have
to go to work
in the back okay now go who's Eddie work
for the new book Tom Cruise you know for
tag I brought it and now I won't do a
movie if I can't bring my family yeah
it's like now everything's different
yeah but they've seen they I saw him in
the new spider-man and or the voice of
it and they hadn't seen very much and
there was an ad we were watching Peter
Rabbit up in Big Bear over Memorial Day
and before that movie starts there's a
bunch of trailers and the spider-verse
one into the spider-verse one starts and
I was like oh there's a trailer on this
and my wife goes is that the one you're
in and I go yeah and they go Daddy
you're in this and it's all Shammi doing
Miles Morales
so in ease jumper on the spider-man
outfit so because there's like a lot of
spider-man's so they go is that you and
I go like no no no like is that one
you're like no and then at the end of
the trailer for a second my character
put like pops up and I go like that's me
and then it ends and it was the first
time my daughter's realize like Who I am
in this business they went like
okay but so yeah at this point now I
don't care about it right how was it
working with Tom Cruise he's a nice guy
yeah well he's really professional and
he's really intense and so I'm a pretty
intense guy and he took my intensity he
made me just feel I was like oh this guy
is at a whole nother level his intensity
is everything like he doesn't drink one
espresso he'll drink town of omen if he
likes espresso then he gets the best
beans of anyone who makes his bread for
real we were in Africa shooting and he
likes espresso yeah and I never had it
before I headed with him but I'm like
yeah it is good all of a sudden there's
a little Colombian guy near craft
service with a little machine making
espresso from the crew and I went I
introduced myself and I was like what
are you doing in Libya magnet he said I
won a contest for like best beans and
best expresso beans in my home country
I'd won my family won like three years
in a row one year like Tom Cruise and
his people come out we they try the
beans they like it he now flies me out
to give his espresso beans to his crew
and himself and I went up I'm like this
is great he's like I know it's the best
it's the best espresso you'll get so
that kind of intensity is it really fun
to be around especially if you're just
at the party for a few months cuz
everything gets escalate and you get to
experience it you're like oh great man
like this is all I'm like man I get it
this is really good espresso I'm never
gonna have it like this again but it's
fun to be around you for four months
that's probably why he does his own
stunts I could do it myself he loves it
everything's got to be done by me yeah I
can I could just imagine you kind of
have Serengeti Zach sent a little bit
I'm wondering if you guys have a secret
thing where I'm gonna be reveal that
you've done some of that song and the
end of this the bids gonna be like dummy
it was me that's why I mean we've
written some stuff together we've come
up together I mean I've known him
like yeah he's one of my best friends
that's fine we have you we we go way
back oh that's fun yeah did he know that
one was gonna pop a little bit or was
that just yeah I mean I was I was with
him in the studio when he was doing that
and it was just we were all just
laughing like cuz before he recorded
that song he we just he kept saying
stuff like that he kept saying favor
doctor 35 dose and like Zach's bears yes
and he was working on beer trucks and he
had come home one day to watch a little
league game and they're interviewing
little kids like what's your favorite
actor you know and they would say you
know Tom Cruise and then he just thought
it'd be funny like wouldn't that be
funny or Foreman was like so that's like
the story behind this yeah yeah I mean
get your like yeah we're like brothers
yeah all right before we bring this home
yeah this is gonna be out well the
premieres tomorrow they were gonna
probably go put this out Sunday or
Monday or the movie comes what a movie
comes out but I think I need to figure
out we need to figure out a premiere
prank or something to do well what are
you gonna do with the spider-man guy
you're bringing him I don't know should
I bring him I mean I think that's a
given he just walks the red carpet with
you yeah
yeah even if there's another prank I
think you should just have him at all
your premiere yeah okay hit him up but
you know there's always the guy doing
the interview and then there's like the
PR person standing behind him even if
he's just standing behind you yeah it's
just that extra thing in the background
yeah just for the pitches yeah he's just
there and then tried to get him in one
group shot where it's like the whole
cast and like Tomczyk will be there Todd
garner will jump in tell him that get in
here okay so that there's one group shot
everybody goes something's up after this
but is there another one announcements
weird announcements announced tada
or was it do I say I'm in a relationship
announce that you're saw your
Scientologist that did that be a [ __ ]
yeah I got I got a question for you
because me and Hannibal we're talking
about this Hannibal has been taking
capoeira once well yeah yeah so we want
so I want Hannibal to pursue capoeira
and get good but I want him to grow
dreadlocks too oh my god my entire look
for her sure you know who knows when I'm
on I'm on this fitness journey on this
right 100% the season so far away oh I
got a a promotional thing we could do it
the press thing was that you could try
to get this podcast to do interviews on
the red carpet yeah and then but you but
only you do the red carpet and then
wheat so the Warner Brothers people
everybody knows like this is Hannibal's
guy yeah I'll agree to come on get John
anybody would say yes to come on as you
walk down the line when it gets to hand
will throw something on them and start a
little like ruckus on YouTube you have
like celebrities getting mad yeah and
it'll be like during a thing like
somebody with her like ketchup on
someone's jack and say don't wear that
and there's a whole thing yeah he could
do something where if you guys plan it
nobody else knows it's planned then the
whole red carpet has this weird feeling
towards it o-o cuz everybody's like what
happened nobody talk to him again nobody
talked to that guy why if something just
happened with Hannibal and that got me
over here I'm the interviewer you're the
interviewer you're interviewing for one
of your episodes of this yeah yeah it's
the it's this podcast going on the red
carpet special no and then when it gets
to handle you guys get in a fight about
something you pretend you didn't want
him to come he's trying to take your
spotlight this is about Hannibal Burres
the actor not the podcast guys you guys
a little back and filming yeah yeah
throw some I've beef yeah throw
something out of security will take you
out but yeah no one's gonna press
charges they'll just get rid of it yeah
but what if I get what if I get like
chokeslam then look really bad it'll be
great for the camera
yeah right it will not feel good they
won't choke yet yeah they won't Sookie
plus you know Wing Chun yeah but if I
fight you fight here's any of that you
guys alright that's assault
it's a solid plan so there's an option
let's close out the show with a with a
song any any song subject suggestions
it's gotta be tight it's gotta be tight
okay yeah you wanna you wanna try out a
little bit just a new change centers
like that that takes it back to your
voice and then that's the
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's the best I like this room
go sounds fun
thanks man June 15 dad 250 tech Thank
You Jake Johnson for coming through
Cheyenne in the house represent
[Music]